so why should we tell a country
to support democracy as a system when we
didn't support democracy in earlier
stages of our development that's a very
good question
why should we tell a country to respect
human rights
when we didn't in an earlier stage in
our development why should we tell a
country not to engage in slavery when we
didn't do that at an earlier stage
development that's a hard argument to
swallow right it doesn't feel good look
I completely understand that it is
actually not fashionable
to take this side of the argument but at
the same time
the notion
of by the people
and for the people
intrinsically feels right to us
running a country
being in having that kind of power being
invested in anyone but us
is problematic
we don't trust anyone with that sort of
power except maybe the Canadians
we don't trust individuals to run it
without checks and balances without
legitimacy without the ability to throw
them out if they do a bad job or when
they appoint their son since it's rarely
their daughter we don't like it
that's that's one reason
I think that we should pay attention to
what we think
deep down on that
second point
to Martin Russian authoritarianism
no question Yeltsin came in
short-term efforts of democracy failed
I'm sure we all agree that Putin's
authoritarianism has been much better
for Russia
right
it's not true
Putin's very powerful he's very rich he
he uses every mode of conveyance I've
ever seen in my life and he and he
transport any animal he he's all over it
he looks good
to some people
um
but but the fact is that he's enriched
himself
on the backs of at the expense of the
Russian people The Brain Drain has been
phenomenal the capital flight has been
huge Egypt democracy
what a failure there was no democracy in
Egypt the military ran the country we
had an Arab Spring everyone got excited
how wonderful the military never went
anywhere
they still controlled the country Arab
monarchies how do we think they work do
we think they'd be better off if there
was actually more representation how
would women be treated in those Arab
monarchies a little better I think so do
we like that sure should we be telling
them what to do with women what do you
think the Arab women would say I know
what they'd say
they like a different system that's not
the West shoving it down their throat I
hate the idea of American exceptionalism
I don't want to tell people how to run
their system look at the way we run our
system isn't it a disaster
the fact that the U.S government today
is less popular does not mean that
democracy is less popular in America
it actually means that people want to
return to Democracy in America
I completely agree with Martin
that China is the interesting case here
right the Arab states are not Russia is
not it's very clear in so many countries
of the world that they would be run
better for their people if there was
more democracy and accountability it's
very clear right in China for 35 years
they've been growing and on average 10
percent a year
and the world's never seen that 1.3
billion people that's very impressive
but what interests me in China
is that they understand
that that's not sustainable
if they don't have the ability
to tell their people that there's a
reason that you vote for us besides
throwing you 10 growth every year
they're in very serious trouble because
you know what happens in an
authoritarian regime when you lose power
they don't just vote you out
it's worse than that
the Chinese government the most
successful authoritarian Revolution and
experiment
that the world has ever seen over 35
years even they understand that if they
don't create a more democratic system
they're gone too
if they recognize it what does it mean
for the rest of us thank you very much
in Bremer thank you very much indeed now
uh our second final speaker for the
motion Rosemary Hollis professor of
Middle East studies and expert on
conflict and Security in the region also
director of The Olive Tree scholarship
program at City University here in
London please welcome Rosemary holders
a lot of nonsense is talked about
democracy and mostly by people who live
in relatively Rich Western democracies
who attribute
their comparative wealth and well-being
to
of course first their own hard work
second
their liberal capitalist system
and thirdly their democratic form of
government
in other words the benefits of democracy
are relative
it depends on who you are
Where You Are
in the global system
how wealthy your state is compared to
others
and where you are in the evolution of
your own political system
now first looking about who you are
supposing you are a member of a minority
Community an ethnic or religious
minority for example a basque separatist
in Spain a Jew in Nazi Germany a Turk in
Germany
how well will majority rule protect you
democracy does not automatically do so
your safety depends on the values
espoused by the government of the day
and a populist government may win
election by playing to majority
prejudices
at the expense of the minorities
why else would religious minority
communities sometimes feel safer under
dictatorial rule than majority rule
the benefits of democracy all depend
whether you draw the lines on the map
around the Democracy concerned
for ordinary Indians who do have a
democracy and Chinese who do not
what matters is that their government is
strong enough
to defend their National corner
they're not operating in a vacuum
democracy or otherwise
thus whether they have a say in the
composition of their government is less
relevant to their chances of prosperity
than the ability of their government to
exercise leverage at the international
level
suppose you live in a small
underdeveloped country dependent on
investment and aid from the developed
world for you
to achieve
a halfway decent standard of living and
gainful employment
whether elected or not your government
will have to bow to the dictates of
multinationals and international
financial institutions whose priorities
are respectively
profits and Loan repayments not your
well-being
your democracy is meaningless when your
government has no real power
in any case politicians are Masters at
managing National perceptions
manufacturing consent even
and I contend the Western democracy's
mistake their moral Authority at home as
a license to tell other people how they
should govern themselves
but their own systems are non-exportable
do not please ladies and gentlemen
equate the word democracy with what
makes you feel good here
because
it cannot work
without the comparative economic
advantages that are enjoyed here
thank you
[Applause]